ENCOURAGE CNN TO CARE ABOUT
JOURNALISTIC INTEGRITY
BEFORE THEY ARE CALLED OUT
FOR BACKING DICTATORS.
WELL, FACEBOOK'S DISASTROUS
WEEK CONTINUING TO GET EVEN
WORSE THANKS TO ANOTHER
SCANDAL.
IN 2012 IT TURNS OUT THE
COMPANY HANDED OVER USER
DATA TO BARACK OBAMA'S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
IN DOING SO, MAY HAVE
VIOLATED THE LAW.
FOX NEWS IT 24/7 HEADLINES
ANCHOR BRET LARSON HAS MORE
ON THAT.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> HEY, TUCKER.
YEAH, NOT A GOOD WEEK TO BE
FACEBOOK BASICALLY.
WHAT WE'RE FINDING OUT TODAY
IS THERE ARE REPORTS THAT IN
2012 THEY MAY HAVE JUST
GIVEN USER DATA TO THE
BARACK OBAMA CAMPAIGN.
THERE WERE REPORTS IN THE
DAILY MAIL FORMER PEPPER
THAT RAN THE CAMPAIGN SOCIAL
MEDIA FOR HIM SOMEONE AT
FACEBOOK SAID WE ARE GIVING
THIS TO YOU BECAUSE WE AGREE
WITH YOU.
OF COURSE, GIVING THEM THAT
INFORMATION FOR FREE WOULD
BE A VIOLATION OF THE
FEDERAL CAMPAIGN FINANCE
LAWS BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE
VIOLATION OF RATHER DIRECT
OR INDIRECT GIVING OF --
THEY ARE BASICALLY GIVING A
CAMPAIGN DONATION IN THAT
SITUATION.
AND YOU CAN'T DO THAT IN
FEDERAL ELECTIONS.
FOR THE PRESIDENT AND FOR
CONGRESS.
THEN WE ARE ALSO LEARNING
TODAY THAT HILLARY CLINTON'S
NAME COMING UP ONCE AGAIN
NOW CONNECTED TO ALL THE
PROBLEMS WITH FACEBOOK THAT
THE APP. SHE WAS USING
DURING THE 2016 CAMPAIGN AND
THEY WERE ENCOURAGING PEOPLE
TO CONNECT WITH THEIR
FRIENDS.
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN GOING
THROUGH YOUR CONTACTS LIST
AND DOING THAT ILLEGALLY AND
TAKING THE DATA OF THEIR
USERS TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
VOTE FOR HILLARY CLINTON TO
TRY AND FIND PEOPLE THAT
THEY COULD PERSUADE TO BE
VOTERS.
NOT VERY GOOD NEWS FOR
FACEBOOK ALL AROUND.
AND THIS IS ALL IN LIGHT OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY ARE
HAVING WITH THE CAMBRIDGE
ANALYTICA STORY THAT WE HAVE
BEEN FOLLOWING FOR THE PAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS WITH THE
50 MILLION USERS AND THE
DATA THAT WAS TAKEN FROM
THEM.
AND THEN THIS VERY, I THINK,
DAMNING PIECE OF INFORMATION
BUZZFEED IS REPORTING ON,
THIS A FORMER FACEBOOK
EXECUTIVE SAYING SOMETHING
ABOUT WHAT THEIR SITE DOES
AND HOW THEY CONNECT PEOPLE
AND HE, IN PART, SAYS ABOUT
ALLOWS US TO CONNECT MORE
PEOPLE MORE OFTEN IS DE
FACTO GOOD.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY
HAD CONCERNS THAT DOING THIS
COULD EVEN ALLOW SOMEONE TO
COORDINATE A TERRORIST
ATTACK OR EVEN EXPOSE
SOMEONE TO BULLYING.
SO, TUCKER, IT IS A BAD WEEK
TO BE FACEBOOK.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
AND IT SHOULD BE.